continuent d'évoquer ce treizième
week-end de mobilisation avec kate
daniel leca vice-président du délit de
la région d'île-de-france et aurélien
véron conseiller les républicains à la
mairie de paris porte parole du groupe
changer paris
bonjour merci messieurs merci de
répondre à nos questions cet après midi
ces manifestations interviennent alors
que le ministère de la santé a annoncé
ce matin que les autotests ne serviront
plus pour le pass sanitaires il n'y aura
plus de remboursement également pour les
tests pcr et antigénique pour les non
vaccinés dès vendredi aurélien véron est
ce que c'est une obligation vaccinale
cacher
donc c'est une stat choix collectif
c'est à dire que l'état rembourse un
vaccin qui aujourd'hui fait ses preuves
un vaccin qui a permis de faire chuter
les chiffres de contamination
ceux qui refusent ce vaccin qui est
totalement gratuit et ouvert à tous et
encore des centres de vaccination
ouverts partout en france bah s'expose à
devoir payer le confort le fasse et pas
du confort c'est le choix personnel de
ne pas se faire vacciner on peut pas
souffrir des pcr tous les quinze jours
c'est pas un luxe c'est un luxe que la
france ne pas se payer
daniel leca certains n'ont donc pas les
moyens de payer 44 22 euros tous les
trois jours est-ce qu'à une politique
qui à deux vitesses de la part du
gouvernement a certes le gouvernement à
prévoir un déficit de 21 6 milliards
d'euros en 2022
mais ça qui te payait sa manifestants
d'aujourd'hui
écoutez franchement monsieur verrons a
dit l'essentiel je vois mal comment on
peut continuer
d'une certaine manière payer un choix
qui est totalement libre mais qui pèse
sur la communauté
à un moment donné vous avez un vaccin
qui est gratuit qui a fait ses preuves
qui aujourd'hui dont on peut aujourd'hui
considérer qu'on a le recul suffisant et
vous avez une poignée de personnes qui
font le choix de ne pas faire vacciner
faisant peser un risque pour eux mêmes
et pour les autres et donc il n'a pas il
n'y a aucune raison que nous allions
collectivement payer pour le choix de
quelques-uns qui met en péril le
collectif donc on va part j'estime que
il y a là un choix individuel et bien à
eux de d'assumer ce choix individuels
d'une part de se priver d'une partie de
liberté c'est vrai la liberté d'aller au
restaurant la liberté de pouvoir avoir
accès et un certain nombre de lieux mais
s'ils souhaitent ils doivent payer sans
paraître aujourd'hui une évidence et la
solidarité a ses limites messieurs
comment est-ce que vous réagissez aux ni
aux images que l'on vient de voir
d'olivier molinari et sébastien dufour
et aux différentes interviews qu on a
entendu de manifestants ou personnalités
politiques comme on a vu avec florian
philippot par exemple aurélien véron je
continuais à voir je peux comprendre une
colère une pandémie mondiale qui était
beaucoup de monde on est toujours dedans
se rend compte qu'au bout de 18 mois
s'est pas terminée donc mais le lait
nous sommes tous stressés on est tous
très si on sait pas comment 2022 va se
passer on constate et je suis heureux de
le voir que les chiffres sont rassurants
que finalement la politique sanitaire
mot n'est donc pas seulement en france
mais partout dans les pays qui ont
appliqué cette politique de vaccination
de test et de passe ça a marché
aujourd'hui on approche du verre on va
voir j'espère que l'hiver va pas faire
rebondir une vague de qu'ovide mais je
vois dans les réactions vous avez filmé
toujours ce symptôme 2 référendum
vaccinale le vaccin n'est pas un
référendum quand je me suis fait
vacciner je n'ai pas signé que je
soutenais macron je suis très critique
de la politique macro mais le vaccin et
des recommandés par des scientifiques et
les politiques n'ont fait qu'obéir aux
recommandations des scientifiques les
publications pas seulement en france
dans le monde entier scientifiques
officiels publics défense de principes
vaccinale est le principe de ces
relations le pass and i ter a été
préconisée par pas mal de scientifiques
dans le monde mais c'est pas français
donc dire je n'ai pas confiance en
eux-mêmes macron je vois pas le rapport
avec le fait de se vacciner ou pas le
fait vaccinale c'est un choix vis-à-vis
de la science c'est un choix dans lequel
il ya des ja le vaccin ne protège pas à
100% mais protège à 99% donc
effectivement c'est pas un parapluie
complet simpara plus presque complet il
ya quelques effets négatifs très
marginaux mais quand vous comparez les
îles comme la guye comme comme la
guadeloupe et la martinique voyais les
effets secondaires des noms 26 né sont
très supérieurs aux effets secondaires
des vaccinés comme à paris on et 88% et
vaccinés ont mis dans la balance vous
constatez assez rapidement si vous
regardez le pour et le contre que la
vaccination et puis là là le bateau le
la voiture balai qui vous oblige à vous
faire vacciner vous qui vous incite à
vous faire vacciner ça marche
daniele cas comment expliquer cette
résilience des manifestants aujourd'hui
dans les rues 13e samedi de mobilisation
peut considérer que d'une part on cette
dynamique en même temps tu as eu à se
tarir progressivement il ya de moins en
moins de monde dans les rues première
chose deuxième chose je crois qu'il faut
mettre en parallèle ceux qui manifestent
et ceux qui sont fait vacciner suite à
la décision de la mise en place du ps
sanitaires on s'est rendu compte qu'il y
avait eu dynamique très forte pour le
vaccin avec effectivement une à un
accroissement très important du nombre
de personnes qui ont fait le choix de se
faire vacciner en conscience je souligne
et je crois qu'il faut le dire qu'il ya
évidemment un problème de confiance ce
problème de confiance on va pas les
régler en un claquement de doigts c'est
de la pédagogie et d'explication et puis
il part oui aussi d'incitation et le
passé n'était qu'une citation par contre
j'ai un peu plus gênés avec une propos
de quelques responsables politiques
espèrent se refaire excusez moi du terme
se refaire la cerise sur une inquiétude
ceux qui agitent les peurs pour faire
grossir leur cote de popularité qui est
plus qu éteinte ça me gêne vous paraît
clairement je ne leur accordent à
notamment monsieur philippot dont on
sait que malheureusement pour lui il a
une audience plus que limité et qui
pense qu'il va pouvoir exister au
travers de cette inquiétude là moi je
pense qu'on fait pas de la politique sur
les peurs et que notre responsabilité
c'est de regarder les choses en
confiance et d'accompagner par la
pédagogie et bien celles et ceux qui
doutent pour faire en sorte qu'on puisse
reprendre le plus rapidement possible
une vie normale alors le vaccin c'est
pas l'alpha et l'oméga il faut continuer
les gestes barrière il faut continuer le
masque quand c'est nécessaire il faut
évidemment rester prudent mais
l'ensemble de ses processus d'une
certaine manière l'ensemble de ces
sécurités mises bout-à-bout nous
permettre d'avoir des chiffres
aujourd'hui plutôt rassurant et qui nous
permettent d'aborder l'hiver de manière
un peu plus sereine et puis ayons
conscience d'une chose un plus on attend
plus on est fragile notamment les
personnes n'est plus loin de l'emploi
qui seront d'autant plus loin de
l'emploi si on ne sait pas redémarrer
notre système économique est si on a
encore une période de confinement même
allégé ce sera dévastateur pour le pays
donc il faut être responsable il faut
être sérieux et en l'occurrence moi je
n'accorde que peu de crédit à toutes
celles et tous ceux qui font de la
politique sur l'épaule la semaine
dernière il y avait 2 il y avait
l'habitude et des hausses des prix de
l'énergie
cette actualité qui s'est agrégé dans
les revendications des mobilisations
anti passe sanitaires mardi également
une manifestation des syndicats 85 mille
manifestants selon le ministère de
l'intérieur 160000 d'après les
organisateurs à six mois des élections
présidentielles est ce qu'il ya une
convergence des luttes qui voit le jour
sous un aspect protéiforme à travers
toutes ces manifestations environ
moi je moi je sens pays fatigué mais
fatigué on a on a d'abord on sort de 18
mois de crise mondiale parce que la
pandémie a paralysé le monde entier les
jeunes sont là que beaucoup de jeunes
font la queue pour à des paniers
alimentaires on dirait stress économique
y est ré ce psychologique et 1,13 ce
d'isolement donc il est naturel que
sortir d'une pandémie à sortir on voit
les nuages s'est dégagée mais la
pandémie est toujours là ce stress soit
présent et on n'est pas le seul pays
concerné ensuite on a un modèle
économique qui arrivait un petit peu au
bout du rouleau avec un taux de chômage
élevé on l'a vu descendre ce mail macron
mais quand le pays fait cocorico avec un
taux de chômage de 8% avant la crise 8%
nos voisins du nord ils sont à trois et
demi 4 % fin il était à trois et demi 4
% et c'était donc moins de la moitié de
notre tour et nous avec un 1500
quartiers prioritaires qui sont qui ne
sont pas traités avec un taux de
déscolarisation dans ces quartiers
bientôt très élevé un taux de chômage
encore plus élevé qu'au débat national
donc évidemment le pays la france un
système un modèle économique un modèle
social qui est fatigué vous ajoutez ça
la pandémie vie d'un angle au stress est
important vous sentez d'ailleurs que
l'élection présidentielle démarre d'une
manière assez inattendue
avec des rondes et des candidats
nouveaux qui sont
dans le registre quand même de du
clivage et de l'affrontement plutôt que
du rassemblement mais à force de
toujours refusé d'affronter les
problèmes de notre modèle économique et
social on en arrive à des doutes
identitaire à des crispations
irrationnelle qui sont à l'avantagé des
prêcheurs de peur
dans la rue aujourd'hui par exemple
pourtant pour l'instant tout à l'air de
bien se passer même les cas légers qui
est sur place a noté quelques tensions
tout à l'heure entre forces de l'ordre
et m et manifestants mais c'est
dans les rues aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
grand monde dans les rues soyons clairs
on est très très loin du mouvement de
gilet jaune au départ on est très très
loin des grands mouvements sociaux et
quand les syndicats manifestent à 80 ou
100 mille cent soixante mille du style
je pense que le comptage de 92 est assez
fiable on est très très loin des grandes
manifestations donc pour l'instant les
gens sont inquiets dans plein de milieux
sociaux pour plein de différentes
raisons qui ne coagule pas à mon sens
mais qui se juxtaposent et les gens sont
plutôt dont la dent dans la recherche
d'un candidat qui répondent à des
préoccupations qui sont pas forcément
rationnelle longe cette présidentielle
ça va être non pas de se laisser
entraîner sur le terrain de
l'irrationnel de la crispation
identitaire des peurs mais plutôt de de
faire émerger une vraie stratégie
aurait n'y avait rien n'est plus sûr la
manifestation qui a lieu en ce moment
même l'ambiance pour l'instant elle est
bonne enfant est ce qu'elle va le rester
selon vous daniel leca
je pense que j'espère qu'elle va le
rester je pense sincèrement que bien sûr
qu'il ya une addition d'inquiétude et
vous l'avez dit un bien sûr que la
question du pouvoir d'achat
est bien présente dans les esprits
évidemment qu'il y a une vraie réflexion
autour de ce que devront chasse que
seront les libertés ou est-ce que ce
seront les
perspectives économiques au lendemain de
volant demain j'espère de la crise que
nous venons de traverser donc toutes ces
inquiétudes existent pour autant
aujourd'hui le vrai sujet il est de
savoir comment on va préparer et je le
dis un débat démocratique qui arrive ce
sera l'occasion pour tous les
mécontentements exprimés ou au contraire
ceux qui sont satisfaits aussi pouvoir
s'exprimer le débat démocratique qui
s'ouvre c'est celui qui alors on peut
s'en féliciter ou pas mais en tout cas
c'est le débat présidentiel qui rythme
la vie démocratique de notre pays et
c'est là où devront s'exprimer
les plus encore une fois les
satisfactions où les mécontentements et
c'est là où l'on verra quels sont les
sujets importants pour le pays on a
aujourd'hui effectivement quelques
quelques expressions extrêmes qui se
manifestent les français sont pas encore
entrés dans le débat présidentiel sont
pas encore entrés demi qu'on d'ailleurs
y compris dans le débat social au fond
on a une minorité absolue de gens qui se
mobilisent aujourd'hui il faut les
écouter il faut les hante que ça traduit
quelque chose mais ne faisons pas de ces
expressions une généralité il ya
aujourd'hui vraiment besoin en réalité
de rassembler de rassurer et de faire en
sorte que les français se projettent
dans l'avenir et s'engage s'engage pas
politiquement et s'engage dans la
reprise de la vie et notamment la vie
économique c'est ça la priorité et tous
les débats qui sont aujourd'hui présents
et qui sont des sujets d'inquiétude
seront tranchés par le débat
présidentiel débat démocratique qui est
devant nous donc manif il y ait des
manifestations s'est défini qui
traduisent un futur un futur débat pour
pour la suite merci messieurs d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je m'appelle
daniel leca que vous êtes vice-président
du délire de la région des hauts de
france et aurélien véron conseillé à
l'air à la mairie de paris porte parole
du groupe changer paris